all the time we see articles popping up
claiming to expose the wealth inequality
of the richest people in the world we
see things like the top 1% of the people
in the world own 44 percent of the
wealth in the world but really these
articles are quite misleading and simply
grow hatred and resentment for the top
1% we think about it the top 1% of the
world encompasses well over 70 million
people covering a very diverse group so
before you go about hating on Jeff Bezos
or Warren Buffett think about this to be
in the top 1% of wage earners in the
world you only have to make 30 2004 as
of September 2019 so who really is to
the top 1%
considering this if you have that time
and resources to be watching this video
you're probably in the 1% or very close
to it so whenever you point out the
wealth inequality in the world chances
are you're complaining about yourself
given this where do billionaires and
people with hundreds of million dollars
in net worth stand well starting off the
most amount of available statistics
focused on the US so this video will
also focus on the u.s. first let's
establish that the average American is
already in the top 1%
given that the mean income last year was
over $63,000 looking deeper into this
population in the US the top 1% is
composed of people who have an annual
household income of $386,000 maybe they
own a popular gas station in town or own
a local grocery store or they may also
have a high paying job like an
anesthesiologist or cardio or
neurosurgeon clearly while these people
are well-off they're not who we are
looking for these people may be your
neighbors and you probably run into them
on a regular basis so let's look one
step further into the top point one
percent of America to be classified in
this category an individual would have
to make between 1.6 and 2.9 million
dollars a year this is the first step
that you'll see of people with
multimillion-dollar houses and expensive
sports cars or at least the first step
that can comfortably afford them but
these people are probably also local
business owners but on a larger scale
they may own a car dealership or operate
a local grocery chain these people are
definitely wealthy but still not the
group we're looking for going one step
deeper the top of 0.01% of America make
between 7.5 million and 18.9 million
dollars now while a large income these
people are also probably just local
dishonours or investors they may own
several apartment complexes in a given
region or maybe operate a statewide
grocery store fortune 500 CEOs who
didn't create their own companies
generally make incomes in this range as
well but they are not the majority in
this
these people have an average net worth
of 371 million dollars and can afford
most of things we classified as top 1%
purchases like private jets or yachts
and these are the people we usually
think of when we think top 1% but let's
take a look at where these people really
stand if we assume the average American
is already the top 1% in the world these
guys are the top 1% of the top 1% of the
top 1% but this is still nowhere near
the end to put this in perspective Jeff
Bezos made seventy eight point five
billion dollars in 2018
this means that Jeff Bezos would make
what the top 1% of the 1% of the 1% of
the world made over their entire career
their net worth in less than two days
now of course Jeff Bezos isn't making
seventy eight billion dollars every
single year but this helps visualize
what is really possible so let's go one
step deeper people who make over 20
million dollars a year this does include
some fortune 500 CEOs and national chain
owners but the vast majority of these
people are investors both in real estate
and the financial industry this is the
final range where you'll find people who
are still working jobs with the top
paying job in the world big hedge fund
managers in fact the top 25 hedge fund
managers in 2017 made six hundred and
fifteen million dollars each on average
we don't exactly know how many people
are within this range some are
billionaires while others are on their
way there moving on let's take a look at
the billionaires with a net worth under
ten billion dollars right now only 120
out of the over 2000 billionaires in the
US have crossed the ten billion dollar
mark this is the vast majority of
billionaires and people you have
probably never heard of
these people are mostly investors and
some are owners of companies that you
are familiar with if you're a
billionaire you're in the top zero point
zero zero zero zero two percent of the
world and finally here is the category
of billionaires that you are
most familiar with networked over 10
billion dollars this category currently
holds 120 people and again you probably
don't even recognize most of them
however most of the barriers you do know
fall into this category this category is
at top 0.000001 6% or the 1% of the 1%
of the 1% of the top 1% of the world so
given all of this information here is a
more realistic view of the top 1% of the
world if you're not struggling to put
food on the table you're likely within
the top 1% the affluent people you know
like doctors and local business owners
fall into top 0.01% next the top 0.0001
percent are the people you would think
or the top 1% that top 0.000 of 0 2% is
made of billionaires you don't know and
finally the few billionaires you know
and complain about fall into the top
0.000001 6% so before you complain about
the wealth inequality realize that
you're likely part of the problem
instead be grateful for how much you
already have and instead of being
jealous of the top donors use them as
inspiration after all you just have to
be 1/1000 as successful as Jeff Bezos to
be worth over 100 million dollars but
that's just what I think if you guys
thought this video provided a thorough
analysis of the top 1% then make sure
drop a like and consider subscribing
because I see more questions just like
this one logically answered but until
then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the
next one